Seth Doane is in the Palestines  Palestinian city of Ramallah in the West  Bank this morning Seth good morning good  morning many Palestinians here in  Ramallah are angered and frustrated by  the u.s. plan to move its embassy from  Tel Aviv to Jerusalem thus marking that  the u.s. sees Jerusalem as the capital  of Israel across Jerusalem there are  signs up thanking America and thanking  President Trump and at the sight of that  new US Embassy final preparations are  underway for a big celebration planned  for Monday but that day also coincides  with planned demonstrations by  Palestinians who see that day as their  quote day of disaster which marks the  70th anniversary since the State of  Israel was declared the Israeli military  is bracing for more violence and more  demonstrations but there is a fine line  if they crack down on the Palestinians  too hard they risk more casualties and  Jericka further in flaming emotions  Thank You Seth Seth Doane in Ramallah